OK, here's linear
algebra lecture seven.
I've been talking
about vector spaces
and specially the
null space of a matrix
and the column
space of a matrix.
What's in those spaces.
Now I want to actually
describe them.
How do you describe
all the vectors
that are in those spaces?
How do you compute these things?
So this is the, turning
the idea, the definition,
into an algorithm.
What's the algorithm
for solving A x =0?
So that's the null space
that I'm interested in.
So can I take a particular
matrix A and describe
the natural algorithm, and I'll
execute it for that matrix --
here we go.
So let me take the
matrix as an example.
So we're definitely talking
rectangular matrices in this
chapter.
So I'll make, I'll
have four columns.
And three rows.
Two four six eight and
three six eight ten.
OK.
If I just look at those
columns, and rows, well,
I notice right away
that column two
is a multiple of column one.
It's in the same
direction as column one.
It's not independent.
I'll expect to discover
that in the process.
Actually, with rows, I notice
that that row plus this row
gives the third row.
So the third row
is not independent.
So, all that should
come out of elimination.
So now what I --
my algorithm is elimination,
but extended now
to the rectangular
case, where we
have to continue even if there's
zeros in the pivot position,
we go on.
OK, so let me execute
elimination for that matrix.
My goal is always, while
I'm doing elimination --
I'm not changing the null space.
That's very important, right?
I'm solving A x equals
zero by elimination,
and when I do these operations
that you already know,
when I subtract
a multiple of one
equation from another equation,
I'm not changing the solutions.
So I'm not changing
the null space.
Actually, I changing the
column space, as you'll see.
So you have to pay attention.
What does elimination
leave unchanged?
And the answer is the solutions
to the system are not changed
because I'm doing
the same thing to --
I'm doing a legitimate
operations on the equations.
Of course, on the right
hand side it's always zero,
and I don't plan to
write zero all the time.
OK, so I'm really just
working on the left side,
but the right side is, is
keeping up always zeros.
OK, so what's elimination?
Well, you know where
the first pivot is
and you know what to do
with it.
So can I just take the
first step below here?
So that pivot row is fine.
I take two times that row away
from this one and I get zero
zero.
That's signaling a difficulty.
Two, two twos away from the
six leaves me with a two.
Two twos away from the
eight leaves me with a four.
And now three of
those away from here
is zero, again another
zero, three twos away
from that eight is the
two, three twos away
from that ten is a four.
OK.
That's the first
stage of elimination.
I've got the first
column straight.
So of course I move on
to the second column.
I look in that
position, I see a zero.
I look below it,
hoping for a non-zero
that I can do a row exchange.
But it's zero below.
So that's telling me that
that column is -- well,
what it's really going to be
telling me is that that column
is a combination of
the earlier columns.
It's that second column is
dependent on the earlier
columns.
But I don't stop to think here.
In that column
there's nothing to do.
I go on to the next.
So here's the next pivot.
So there's the first pivot
and there's the second pivot,
and I just keep this
elimination going downwards.
So, so the next step
keeps the first row,
keeps the second
row with its pivot,
so I've got my two pivots,
and does elimination
to clear out the column
below that pivot.
So actually you see
the multiplier is one.
It subtracts row
two from row three
and produces a row of zeros.
OK.
That I would call
that matrix U, right?
That's our upper --
well, I can't quite
say upper triangular.
Maybe upper -- I don't
know -- upper something.
It's in this so-called
echelon form.
The word echelon means,
like, staircase form.
It's the, the non-zeros
come in that staircase form.
If there was another pivot
here, then the staircase
would include that.
But here's a case where
we have two pivots only.
OK, so actually we've already
discovered the most important
number about this matrix.
The number of pivots is two.
That number we will call
the rank of the matrix.
So let me put immediately.
The rank of A --
so I'm telling
you what this word
rank means in the algorithm.
It's equal to the
number of pivots.
And in this case, two.
OK, for me that number
two is the crucial number.
OK, now I go to -- you remember
I'm always solving A x equals
zero, but now I can solve
U x equals zero, right?
Same solution, same null space.
OK.
So I could stop here --
why don't I stop here and
do the back substitution.
So now I have to ask you, how
do I describe the solutions?
There are solutions,
right, to A x equals zero.
I knew there would be.
I had three equations
in four unknowns.
I certainly expected
some solutions.
Now I want to see what are they.
OK, here's the critical step.
I refer to it up here
as separating out
the pivot variables, the pivot
columns, which are these two.
Here I have two pivot columns.
Those, obviously, they're
the columns with the pivots.
So I have two pivot columns.
And I have the other
columns, I'll call free.
These are free columns, OK.
Why do I use those words?
Why do I use that word free?
Because now I want to write, I
want to find the solutions to U
x equals zero.
Here is the way I do it.
These free columns I can assign
any number freely to those --
to the variables x2 and
x4, the ones that multiply
columns two and four.
So I can assign anything
I like to x2 and x4.
And then I can solve the
equations for x1 and x3.
Let me say that again.
If I give -- let
me, let me assign.
So, so one particular x is
to assign, say, the value one
to the, to x2, and zero to x4.
Those are -- that
was a free choice,
but it's a convenient choice.
OK.
Now I want to solve
U x equals zero
and find numbers one and
three, complete the solution.
Can I write down --
let's see.
OK.
Shall we just remember what
U x equals zero represents?
What are my equations?
That first equation
is x1 plus just --
I'm just saying what are
these matrices meaning.
That's the first equation.
And the second equation
was 2x3 + 4x4=0.
Those are my two equations.
OK.
Now the point is I can find x1
and x3 by back substitution.
So we're building on
what we already know.
The new thing is that there
were some free variables that I
could give any numbers to.
And I'm systematically going
to make a choice like this, Now
what is x3?
1 and 0.
Let's, let's go
backwards, back up.
I look at the last equation.
x3 is zero, from
the last equation,
because, because x4
we've set x4 to zero,
and then we get x3 as zero.
OK.
Now we set x2 to be
one, so what is x1?
Negative two, right?
So then I have negative two
plus two, zero and zero,
correctly giving zero.
There is a vector
in the null space.
There is a solution
to A x equals zero.
In fact, what solution is that?
That simply says that minus
two times the first column
plus one times the second
column is the zero column.
Of course that's right.
Minus two of that column plus
one of that, or minus two
of that plus one of that.
That solution is -- that, that's
just what we saw immediately,
that the second column is twice
as big as the first column.
OK, tell me some more
vectors in the null space.
I found one.
Tell me, how to get a bunch more
immediately out of that one.
Just take multiples of it.
Any multiple of --
I could multiply
this by anything.
I might as well call it, I could
say, C, some multiple of this.
So let me --
so X could be any
multiple of this one.
OK, that, that
describes now a line,
an infinitely long line
in four dimensional space.
But -- which is
in the null space.
Is that the whole null space?
No.
I've got two free
variables here.
I made this choice, one and
zero, for the free variables,
but I could have
made another choice.
Let me make the other
choice zero and one.
You see my system.
So let me repeat the system.
This is the algorithm that
you, you just learned to do.
Do elimination.
Decide which are
the pivot columns
and which are the free columns.
That tells you that, that
variables one and three
are pivot variables, two
and four are free variables.
Then those free variables,
you assign them --
you give one of them the value
one and the others the value
zero -- in this case, we
had a one and a zero --
and complete the solution.
And you do -- you give the other
one the value one and zero.
And now complete the solution.
So let's complete that solution.
I'm looking for a vector
in the null space,
and it's absolutely going to
be different from this guy,
because, because any
multiple of that zero
is never going to give the one.
So I have somebody
new in the null space,
and let me finish it
out.
What's x3 here?
So we're going by
back substitution,
looking at this equation.
Now x4 we've changed, we're
doing the other possibility,
where x2 is zero and x4 is one.
So x3 will happen
to be minus two.
And now what do I get
for that first equation?
x1 -- let's see.
Two x3s is minus four plus
two -- do I get a two there?
Perhaps, yeah.
Two for x1, minus four, and two.
OK.
That's in the null space.
What does that say
about the columns?
That says that two of
this column minus two
of this column plus this column
gives zero, which it does.
Two of that minus two
of that and one of that
gives the zero column.
OK, now, now I've found another
vector in the null space.
Now we're ready to tell
me the whole null space.
What are all the
solutions to Ax=0?
I've got this guy
and when I have him,
what else is, goes into the
null space along with that?
These are my two
special solutions.
I call them special --
I just invented that name.
Special solutions.
What's special about them
is the special numbers
I gave to the free variables,
the values zero and one
for the free variables.
I could have given the
free variables any values
and got vectors
in the null space.
But this was a good way to be
sure I got t- got everybody.
OK, so once I have him, I
also have any multiple, right?
So I could take any
multiple of that
and it's in the null space.
And now what else --
I left a little space for what?
What -- a plus sign.
I can take any combination.
Here is a line of vectors
in the null space.
A bunch of solutions.
Would you rather I say in the
null space or would you rather
I say, OK, I'm solving Ax=0?
Well, really I'm solving Ux=0.
Well, OK, let me put in
that crucial plus sign.
I'm taking all the combinations
of my two special solutions.
That's my conclusion there.
The null space contains,
contains exactly
all the combinations of
the special solutions.
And how many special
solutions are there?
There's one for
every free variable.
And how many free
variables are there?
Oh, I mean, we can see
all the whole picture now.
If the rank R was
two, this is the,
this is the number of
pivot variables, right,
because it counted the pivots.
So how many free variables?
Well, you know it's two, right?
What is it in -- for a matrix
that's m rows, n columns,
n variables that
means, with rank r?
How many free variables
have we got left?
If r of the variables are
pivot variables, we have n-r --
in this case four minus
two -- free variables.
Do you see that first of all
we get clean answers here?
We get r pivot variables -- so
there really were r equations
here.
There looked like
three equations,
but there were really only
two independent equations.
And there were n-r variables
that we could choose freely,
and we gave them those
special zero one values,
and we got the
special solutions.
OK.
For me -- we could
stop at that point.
That gives you a
complete algorithm
for finding all the
solutions to A x equals zero.
OK.
Again, you do elimination --
going onward when a column,
when there's nothing
to be done on one column,
you just continue.
There's this number r, the
number of pivots, is crucial,
and it leaves n-r free
variables, which you
give values zero and one to.
I would like to
take one more step.
I would like to clean up
this matrix even more.
So now I'm going to go
to -- this is in its,
this is in echelon form,
upper triangular if you like.
I want to go one more step to
make it as good as it can be.
OK, so now I'm going to speak
about the reduced row echelon
form.
OK, so now I'm going to speak
about the matrix R, which is
the reduced row echelon form.
So what does that mean?
That means I just --
I can, I can work harder on U.
So let me start, let
me suppose I got as far
as U, which was good.
Notice how that row
of zeros appeared.
I didn't comment on
that, but I should have.
That row of zeros up here
is because row three was
a combination of
rows one and two,
and elimination
discovered that fact.
When we get a row of zeros,
that's telling us that the --
original row that was there was
a combination of other rows,
and elimination knocked it out.
OK, so we got this far.
Now how can I clean
that up further?
I can do, elimination upwards.
I can get zero above the pivots.
So this reduced row
echelon form has zeros
above and below the pivots.
So let me do that.
So now I'll subtract one
of this from the row above.
That will leave a zero
and a minus two in there.
And that's good.
OK, and I can clean it
up even one more step.
I can make the pivots --
the pivots I'm going to make
equal to one, because I can
divide equation
two by the pivot.
That won't change the solutions.
So let me do that.
And then I really --
I'm ready to stop.
One, two, zero, minus
two, zero, zero, one, two.
I divided the second
equation by two,
because now I have a one in
the pivot and zeros below.
OK.
This is my matrix R.
I guess I'm hoping
that you could now
execute the whole algorithm.
Matlab will do it immediately
with the command --
reduced row echelon form of A.
So if I input that
original matrix A
and then I write, then I type
that command, press return,
that matrix will appear.
That's the reduced
row echelon form,
and it's got all the
information as clear as can be.
What, what information
has it got?
Well, of course it
immediately tells me
the pivot rows, pivot
rows, one and two,
pivot columns, one and three.
And in fact it's got the
identity matrix in there,
It's, it's got zeros above
and below the pivots, right?
and the pivots are one,
so it's, so it's got a --
so notice the two by two
identity matrix that's sitting
in the pivot rows
and pivot columns.
it's I in the pivot
rows and columns.
It's got zero rows below.
Those are always indicating
that original rows were,
were combinations of other rows.
So we really only
had two rows there.
And now it also -- so
there's the identity.
Now it's also got
its free columns.
And, they're cleaned
up as much as possible.
Actually, actually it's now
so cleaned up that the special
solutions, I can read off --
you remember I went through
the steps of computing this --
doing back substitution?
Let me, let me,
instead of that system,
let me take this
improved system.
So I'm going to use
these numbers, right.
In these equations,
what did I do?
I divided this equation
by two and, oh yeah
and I had subtracted
two of this,
which knocked out this guy
and made that a minus sign.
Is that what --
I've now written Rx equals zero.
Now I guess I'm hoping everybody
in this room understands
the solutions to the
original A x equals zero,
the midway, halfway,
U x equals zero,
and the final R x equals
zero are all the same.
Because going from one
of those to another one
I didn't mess up.
I just multiplied
equations and subtracted
from other equations,
which I'm allowed to do.
OK.
But my point is that now
if I do this free variables
and back substitution, it's
just, the numbers are there.
When I let x -- so in this guy,
I let x2 be one and x4 be zero.
I, I guess, what I seeing here?
Let me, let me sort of
separate this out here.
I'm seeing in the pivot,
in the pivot columns,
if I, if I put the pivot
columns here, I'm seeing those.
And I'm -- in the free
columns I'm seeing --
what I seeing in
the free columns?
A two, zero in that first
free column, the x2 column,
and a minus two, two
in the fourth column,
the other free column.
And the row of zeros below,
which of course have no --
that equation is
zero equals zero.
That's satisfied.
Here's my point.
That when I do
back substitution,
these numbers are
exactly what shows up --
oh, their signs get switched.
I was going to say those
numbers, two, minus two, zero,
two, can I just circle the
-- this is the free part
of the matrix.
This is the identity part.
This is the free part,
maybe I'll call it F.
This, of course, I call I,
because it's the identity.
The free part is a, I mean, I'm
just doing back substitution.
And those free numbers will
show up, with a minus sign,
because they pop onto the
other side of the equation --
so I see minus two, zero,
and I see two, minus two.
So that wasn't magic.
It had to happen.
Let me, show you
clearly why it happened.
OK, so that's --
this is what I'm
interested in here.
And now let me, let me just,
like, do it, do it for --
let's suppose we've,
we've got to --
let's suppose we've got
this system already in,
in rref form.
So my matrix R is --
what does it look like?
OK, and I'll --
let me pretend that the
pivot columns come first
and then whatever's
in the free columns.
And there might be
some zero rows below.
There's a typical --
a pretty typical reduced
row echelon form.
You see what's typical.
It's got -- this is r by r.
This is r pivot rows.
This is r pivot columns.
And here are n-r free columns.
OK.
Tell me what are the
special solutions?
What are the --
what's x?
If I want to solve
R x equals zero --
in fact, let me --
I'm really going to, do
the whole -- since these --
this is now block matrices,
I might as well do all
of the special
solutions at once.
So I want to solve
R x equals zero,
and I'll have some
special solutions.
Let me, actually --
can I do them all at once?
I'm going to create a
null space matrix, OK.
A matrix.
Its, its, its columns
are the special --
the columns are the
special solutions.
This is, I'm making
it sound harder,
it's going to be totally easy.
N will be this
null space matrix.
I want R N to be
the zero matrix.
These columns of N are
supposed to multipl-
to get multiplied by R
and give zero columns.
So what N will do the job?
Let me put --
I'm going to put the identity
in the free variable part
and then minus F will show up
in the pivot variables, just
the way it did in that example.
There we had the identity and F.
Here -- in the special solution.
So these columns are --
there's the matrix of special
solutions.
And actually, there -- so
there's a Matlab command
or a teaching code
command, NULL --
N equal, so this is the --
produces the null basis, the
null space matrix, NULL of A,
and there it is.
And how does that
command actually work?
It uses Matlab to
compute R, then
it picks out the pivot
variables, the free variables,
puts, puts ones and zeros
in for the free variables,
and copies out the
pivot variables.
It, it does back substitution,
but back substitution
for this system
is totally simple.
What is this system?
R x equals zero.
So this is R is I F, and
x is the pivot variables
and the free variables, and
it's supposed to give zero.
So what does that mean?
That means that the
pivot variables plus F
times the free
variables give zero.
So let me put F times the free
variables on the other side.
I get minus F times
the free variables.
There's my, equation,
as simple as it can be.
That's what back
substitution comes
to when I've reduced and
reduced and reduced this system
to the, to the best form, OK.
And, then if the
free variables, I
make this special
choice of the identity,
then the pivot variables are
minus F. OK, can I
do, another example?
Could you do another example?
Can I -- let me just
take another matrix
and, and let's go through
this algorithm once more, OK.
Here we go.
Here's a blackboard
for another matrix, OK.
So I'll call the matrix A
again, but let me make it --
yeah, how big shall
we make it this time?
Why don't I do this?
Just for the heck of it.
Let me take the transpose of
this A and see what happens to
that.
Two four six eight and
three six eight ten.
Before we do the calculations,
tell me what's coming?
How many pivot variables
do you expect here?
How many columns are
going to have pivots?
How many -- we have three
columns in that matrix,
but are we going to, are we
going to have three pivots?
No, because this third columns
is the sum of the first two
columns.
I'm totally expecting, totally
expecting that these will be
pivot columns --
because they're independent,
but that this third guy,
the third column, which is
dependent on the first two,
is going to be a free column.
Elimination better
discover that.
And elimination will
also straighten out
the rows, dependent rows
and some independent rows.
What's the, what's the row
reduced echelon form for this?
Let's just do it, OK.
So, so that's the first pivot.
Two times that away from
that gives me a row of zeros.
that gives me a zero two two.
And two times that away from
that gives me a zero four four.
OK, first column is straight.
First variable is
a pivot variable.
No problem.
On to the second column.
I look at the second
pivot, it's a zero.
I look below it.
There's a two.
OK, I do a row exchange.
So this zero is now there.
I now have a perfectly
good pivot, and I use it.
OK, and I subtract two of
that row away from this row.
All right if I do it like that?
I've got to the form U now.
This was my A.
Now there's my U.
I can see now --
I have to stop, right?
I would go on to
the third column.
I should have tried.
I quit, but without trying.
I shouldn't have done that.
On to the third column,
look at the pivot position.
It's got a zero in it.
Look below, all zeros.
Now I'm entitled to stop, OK.
So the rank is two again.
What about the null space?
How many special solutions
are there this time?
How many special
solutions for this matrix?
I've got -- and which are the
free variables and which are
the pivot variables and so on?
Pivot columns, I've
got two pivot columns,
and that's no accident.
The number of pivot columns
for a matrix A, that's
a great fact, that the
number of pivot columns for A
and A transpose are the same.
And then I have a free column.
There's a free column.
One free column, because the
count is three minus two.
Three minus two gives
me one free column.
OK, so now let me solve,
what's in the null space.
OK, so how do I --
let's see.
These vectors have length three.
They only have three components.
I'm making too much space
for the, to write x.
x has just got three
components, and what are they?
I'm looking for the null space.
OK, so how do I start?
I give the free variable
some convenient value.
And what's that?
I set it to one.
I set the free variable to one.
If I set the free
variable to zero and solve
for the pivot variables, I'll
get all zeros: no progress.
But by setting the
free variable to one --
you see w- my two
equations now are --
my equations are x1+
2x2+ 3 x3 is zero,
that's my first equation.
And my second equation is
now 2x2+2x3 equals zero.
And, OK.
So if x3 is one,
then x2 is minus one.
And if x3 is one and x2 is
minus one, then maybe x1
is minus one.
And actually I go
back to check now.
I don't, like --
I did a quick
calculation mentally.
Can I mentally do a quick check?
That matrix, that
solution x says
that minus this column minus
this column plus this one
is the zero column.
And it is.
Minus that minus that
plus that is zero.
So that's in the null space.
And now you can tell me what
else is in the null space.
What's, what's the
whole null space now?
I multiply by C, right.
The whole null space is a line.
So that's the description.
You know, if I ask you on a
homework or a quiz or the final
what -- give me, describe,
tell me the null space,
find the null space
of this matrix,
you can take those steps.
And that's the answer
I'm looking for.
And I'm looking for that C
too, because that's telling me
that you're remembering that
it's a whole space and not
just one vector.
Later I will ask you for a
basis for the null space.
Then I just want this vector.
But if I ask for the
whole null space,
then there's the whole
line through that vector.
OK, now one more natural thing
to do with this example, right,
is keep going to the
reduced matrix, R.
So can I push onwards to R?
That should be quick,
but let's just practice.
Let me keep going to R.
OK, so what do I do here?
I subtract --
I clear out above
the pivot, so I
subtract that from that, that's
one zero one is left, right?
When I subtracted
this row from this
it produced a zero
above this pivot.
And now I want that
pivot to be a one.
So for the R matrix, I'll
divide this equation by two,
and of course these zero, zeros
are great, they don't change.
There's R.
That's R.
You see what R is?
You see the identity
matrix sitting up here?
You see the free part
F, the F part here?
And you see the zeros below.
This is I F zero zero.
And what's the x?
The x has the identity --
well, it's only a
single number one,
but it's the identity matrix
in the free, in the free part.
And what does it have
in the pivot variables?
What did back substitution give?
It gave minus these guys.
You see that what this
is is any multiple of --
this is the identity there,
and this is minus F here.
This is our null space
matrix N for this.
Our, our null space matrix
is the guy whose columns
are the special solutions.
So their free variables
have the special values
one and, pivot
variables have minus F.
So do you see, though,
how the minus F just
automatically shows up
in the special solutions.
That's it really.
I don't think there's
anything more I
can say about A x equals zero.
There's more I can
say about A x equal b,
but that'll be on Friday.
OK, so that's, that's
the null space.
Thanks.